so why was I so happy to engage in
having this course be ported and
OpenCourseWare well first of all I have
a very deep affection for OpenCourseWare
so because I feel that OpenCourseWare
has this potential to teach to the
billions to share knowledge to unlock
knowledge for people in very far-flung
places very remote places like in Haiti
where there is little access to quality
material so so for me I feel that
openko schools mission is very germane
to myself as a Haitian fact MIT wanting
to share this wealth that I have
intellectually with the rest of the
world including my compatriots in Haiti
we don't have that access that much
access to quality materials but also
when it comes to this issue of breaking
walls and building bridges as we see say
in in in the US in parts of Europe the
world moving to more exclusion to more
walls I feel that the kind of knowledge
that we're building at MIT and how we
are the people we ask as a global
village as we can be as we enrich
ourselves by understanding other
people's experiences be it Muslims and
immigrants and blacks and Latinos it is
worth there so I feel that it's
important to take these these knowledge
these discussions and have it shared
with the whole world so people can see
that there is a different way of
thinking that doesn't involve building
walls for security but instead creating
dialogues with invidia so that we all
can be the richer for it wherever we are
bit in Boston such assets or in
port-au-prince Haiti or in Syria or even
Iran so that that's why I feel supported
that such forces be on OpenCourseWare
for the world to participate in